hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com so in this video i would
like to ask a question so the question
is what might create the squeeze i'm
talking here of course about amc and gme
so let's get into it
[Music]
all right yes so i think
that is very interesting to look at
first
what happened yesterday so i'm going to
quickly go on the charts as usual but
most importantly i would like to really
discuss the most important question that
is what can create the squeeze so first
the charts amc so i'm on a daily time
frame guys let me quickly sum up the
situation here
so we are having since august a nice
bullish development that developed in
five waves here one two three four five
so this is kind of uh normal behavior
then we corrected a bit too deep once
again you can measure how deep we
correct usually we go to 61.8 for second
waves as per elliott wave theory here we
went slightly below to the 78.6 so
already you can see that bears were you
know a bit too much in control in this
move down but finally bulls flex the
muscles we had the breakout we it needed
some time guys before taking back the
moving averages and for now so here then
we had this bullish engulfing that i
showed you guys already we have one here
let me put it up
we have one here and one here all right
and each time after the bullish
engulfing i mean here we went slightly
lower i mean not the next day we went
much higher so each time after the
bullishing i think we have positive
reactions okay so that's kind of
expected uh now what we are waiting for
is uh so we are trading above the moving
averages so once again uh i'm a ta guy
and here there's nothing else i can tell
you and no one else that knows about
here will tell you something different
than from the fact that we are bullish
because we are above the moving averages
we are above 38 that i'm gonna put in
green okay so we have everything but of
course anything can happen and
yesterday's session was to me even if we
closed the day higher it was mixed
the reason why it's mixed to me
so we went to 41.8 yesterday
so we were getting close to where we had
a lot of gamma
so i wish we had a stronger move to be
honest this is weak to me because we had
the gamma we had the positive impulse
that at the early session of training
so we had everything technicals were
good we had the news from the day before
that apes will now try to hold their
shares on the account so everything was
looking great and we didn't have the
squeeze so the question i want to ask is
what else do we need because yesterday
we had everything and we didn't have the
strong move up that could have happened
let's say 20 or you know just go to the
50 area right away this would have been
like here a great success so maybe it's
going to happen on monday maybe people
need to think about the news that is
actually very good because it's the only
way to make the shorts actually squeezed
because you know if those guys can
always bore shares and uh dumping the
market
the squeeze might never happens so this
news once again that is about the fact
that uh apes are now uh holding their
shares physically not through broker but
on uh direct registration accounts is
very good so maybe we're gonna have the
positive reaction on monday but here
what i really want to analyze guys is
what do we need for this quiz to happen
so we first need to think about the
situation so we have apes that hold 80
percent of the share float we have
shorts around so
23
right now on amc so you can see that
everything has not been rolled
uh yet okay so maybe this is gonna give
us some fresh power because we only have
13 percent of synthetic shot right now
max maximum synthetic short which means
that all the options that expired on
october have have not been rolled
yesterday if they were maybe this would
have give us the of energy we missed
so right now the next expiry is 19th of
november
uh maybe there is one more i'm gonna
have a look but we have roughly 23
percent of short interest in this market
so when we look at the previous moves up
for example here here we have identified
that it was uh so on the 1st of october
when we took 20
the s p was dropping heavily that day
and i'm very convinced this was a margin
call so margin calls can create uh the
beginning of a short squeeze all right
this is uh the definition of a short
squeeze right
so uh but i doubt we have those margin
calls at higher levels because as
explained margin calls happen
either
if amc starts to move up you know so we
need fresh money like for example
institutional clients or apes so those
are the two different categories of
investors that can bring fresh liquidity
apes or asset managers basically and we
have shorts that can buy so we have
three categories of buying orders that
can happen in this market and market
makers of course that gonna buy on the
way up through the short gamma position
the bear because they are selling calls
to retail investors so to apes so let's
try to think about this once again
and we can see that right now apes they
have already bought so maybe they're
gonna keep buying but i can see just by
looking for example at uh the views i
make on my youtube channel or any other
youtubers about amc people are not you
know that much into amc as they used to
be i mean people less talk about that
so i think that if amc starts to move
higher again they will again talk about
it and new apes will come so basically
the movement will grow and fresh
liquidity will arrive so this is one way
that this can happen okay there needs to
be something that that makes everybody
talking about amc so strong moves up can
do that
or a news so basically we need catalyzer
so i think that the news we had
yesterday two days ago is something very
great so i hope people will talk about
it
during the weekend just like i'm doing
so that's more people get into the trade
if apes are not the ones that create the
strong move up then it can only come so
hedge funds will not do it by themselves
only if the market is crashing but we
have very positive signals on the global
market right now so i don't think this
could happen and so the last option is
asset managers and asset managers uh you
know they can buy if they are bullish i
mean they can you know inject a lot of
money but same they're not gonna happen
so they can check tm all right those
guys they use cs so if there is a good
tier they can you know put a bit more
money but they're not gonna start to
invest massively
if there is no news
so i come back to the original question
what can create the squeeze and the only
answer i can bring you guys
is the news right it's the only thing
that can make apes talking more about
amc especially if we start to go higher
the virtual cycle will be created again
right now the issue is i think that uh
people don't talk enough about the stock
as they used to
so this is what could for example uh
convince some asset managers to jump in
if they see that every everybody is
talking about amc it will work just like
bitcoin right bitcoin is uh making
almost mi highs not because it's uh
worth a lot just because people it's
worth how much people talk about it
right so the more people gonna talk
about it the higher the it's worse would
be so it's the same for amc guys and
once again i sum up the situation margin
calls will happen but higher or if the
market crashes which is off the table
right now so margin calls won't uh
trigger the move uh the move up apes are
loaded already and
maybe when they're gonna roll they're
gonna bring fresh liquidity but most of
apes have already bought enough shares
as they wanted to so we need new apes to
come the movement to grow to make the
movement grow we need to talk about it
and we need to have the first moves up
okay so fresh liquidity that are gonna
then generate everything but yesterday
we had that it was not enough so my
conclusion is
the movement needs to grow and
and once again a news would help a lot
to do that quickly i'll check gme yes
because those two they are going
together if one is moving it's going to
spread the same way okay uh it's
news driven people would talk about amc
and look at gme and be like hey why is
jamie not taking off and they will be
buying jimmy and talk about it so one or
the other will probably uh trigger the
other one so here
on gme
same situation guys i'm gonna keep
updating you but it can take some time
uh we have a huge triangle that is
converging in jan 22 roughly okay around
200 so something must happen before that
so i don't know
maybe something like this
uh if we break this it's not looking
good but for now we are far far far from
this kind of scenarios this is very
strong here i would personally be a
buyer
again here around 170 if we see this
deep i would be buying more at this
level and yeah technically here it's
looking pretty pretty nice uh we are
above the moving averages
we are above 178 so once again a
pullback can always happen uh that's
that's for sure but we are bullish okay
we are bullish on the long term above
the moving averages bullish on the short
term after breakout and uh close above
the moving averages yeah so let's see
what's happening here but this chart is
looking great to me and once again uh
whenever we break the orange trend line
which level is right now at
pom pom pom around 240 250 uh this is
like i mean almost guaranteed that we're
gonna have a squeeze because if we go
there and we break that it means that we
had already the trigger and that people
talk about it and that everything is in
the right direction so once again talk
about it share this video tell the story
that you want to your friends parents
family whatever just spread the word
that this movement is strong that apes
will hold and that something great is
about to happen
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're going to be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show i'll see you
guys